The Germans passed a new law,
took the cash from the refugees first.
The new law comes into force at the end of January,
on my 31st January of the 20th year,
that is,
January,
there will be no more money transferred to a bank card,
but there will be another card,
and it will be impossible to withdraw cash.
Maximum aa you can withdraw only €50.
The rest can only be spent on food and clothing in certain stores.
Yes,
everything else will be banned.
And this applies not only to Ukrainians who arrived under paragraph 20-4,
this applies to absolutely all refugees,
but I think that over time all social workers will also be affected,
because, first,
the most dependent and the most vulnerable get involved.
population group.
Yeah,
something like that.